accrochés aux coteaux de la vallée du
cher
le vignoble de la roche-blanche vieux de
plus de 150 ans cultivait en
agrobiologie depuis 1992
c'est un véritable laboratoire naturel
ou l'environnement participent à la
qualité du vignoble rien de plus normal
alors que d'y trouver le cheval comme
auxiliaires de culture
geneviève loue ses services et ceux
d'apollon son cheval ardennais aubry du
tracteur elle a préféré le son des
sabots et du cygne en moi je préfère
nettement et derrière cheval il ya une
forcément une complicité
on travaille ensemble c'est un cheval
que j'ai dressé je les lui à deux ans ça
peut paraître simple là aujourd'hui il
ya cinq ans il est mûr il est mature
mais il ya eu trois années des fois
j'avais peur on dit que les chevaux de
trait télé sang froid
à la différence des shows de monte un
donc dé sang froid qui sont a priori
placide tranquille mais ça s'acquiert et
tous malgré tout ne sont pas comme ça et
donc cette sensibilité va après on va
l'aiguiser parce que il est à l'écouté
c'est à dire qu'il faille être douce
faut être souple pour pas voilà la
boutique cheval il faut la respecter
c'est julien le propriétaire du domaine
qui a fait le choix de l'intervention du
cheval dans ses vignes
ça c'était à prévoir à 120 ans voilà un
peu tordu donc mais bon ça remettre à
plat et puis on y travaillera pour la
suite quoi l'écho que geneviève et
clémence en train de travailler est une
parcelle original donc c'est une ville
qu'à 120 ans donc 17 qui sont fragiles
mais qui demande de la douceur que pas
capable d'apporter le tracteur la
traction animale améliore la qualité du
sol et l'espérance de vie des cèpes en
évitant tassement érosion que provoque
poires les vibrations du tracteur
l'utilisation du cheval permet aussi une
meilleure protection des pieds de vigne
en limitant des blessures sur les
racines et le marcottage donc le quai
principal au pied d'origine et est ici
c'est le gros là donc ils se sont servis
d'un grand brun qu'on l'a enfoncé dans
le sol dans la terre et pour faire
repartir un pied donc ça c'est la
marcotte et celles ci on voit bien
qu'elle sait bien dans la cynique
là on a dégagé les racines de surface
c'est pas grave au contraire ce même
mieux et on a une racine une racine qui
a plongé dans la terre met donc ça c'est
impeccable et d'où l'intérêt donc de
faire passer le cheval c'est que ça
c'est un travail de précision
autre acteur a ignoré toutes emporté
enfin tout aurait été cassée alors que
moins du coup des cavaillonnais hb avec
le mouvement engagé mais le cheval quand
ils s'intègrent et dix ans ils
s'arrêtent au 19e siècle 3 millions de
chevaux de trait exister en france au
20ème siècle la politique
d'agrandissement des domaines le faible
coût des carburants organise la
mécanisation agricole aujourd'hui en
réaction une agriculture intensive des
modes de production plus un coexistent
c'est là que le cheval de trait prend
toute sa place en tant qu'outil de
traction écologiquement propre les
grands domaines ne s'y trompe pas elle
illustre par celle de la romanée-conti
élevé en biodynamie avec usage du cheval
maraîchage viticulture et débardage sont
les trois secteurs où travaillent plus
de 400 prestataires et 4 davantage de
débardage de cheval c'est qu'on abîme
pas du tout le milieu de la forêt on
peut aller dans des camps des zones
assez humide dans des zones bien pentue
avec sans détruire l'écosystème clément
ancien maraîcher a fait le choix du
cheval par passion mais aussi dans une
éthique ou écologie agriculture se
conjuguent un choix qui coûte autrement
à la chasse est sûr c'est moins cher
après pendant six mois tracteurs de
chance faut quand la saison est finie on
le met dans le garage
le cheval il faut le nourrir tous les
jours vacances jours fériés et puis du
coup ça c'est un mode de vie on est
toujours faut toujours être un peu
présents pour eux quoi c'est beaucoup de
temps en fait peut-être moins
d'investissements financiers mais séduit
c'est beaucoup plus de temps de travail
une récente étude montre que
l'utilisation du cheval de trait ne
cesse d'augmenter
collecte des déchets entretien des
espaces verts transports scolaires
débardage labour maraîchage tourisme et
loisirs autant de manières de
réintroduire le cheval dans nos paysages
les neuf races de chevaux de trait tout
classe est menacée pourrait bien nous
aider à répondre à des besoins futurs